une nouvelle fois la chanteuse gwen est
obligé de s'exprimer suite à des
nouvelles insultes grosso fob des
insultes montel et malheureusement
régulièrement victimes les insultes et
les railleries dont peuvent faire preuve
les réseaux sociaux en fait c'était déjà
le cas quand j'avais 16 ans c'est lors
de son passage dans la finale de the
voice le 15 mai dernier que plusieurs
internautes se sont acharnés sur la
jeune femme en lui faisant remarquer sa
prise de poids des attaques anonymes et
souvent rédigées par des hommes luan
c'est une artiste et une femme
incroyable un bel humains comme on dit
face à ces messages de haters la
chanteuse a préféré les bombes de façon
douce et sobre par un message sur
twitter
l'offre mice apte à comprendre je même
malgré tout une réponse applaudi par ses
nombreux supporters qui n'ont pas hésité
à publier massivement des messages de
soutien à la chanteuse willow à naples
et du poids mais parce qu'elle a eu un
enfant et elle reste sublime
n'en déplaise orageux label one que nous
retrouverons le 5 juin prochain dans la
chanson de l'année nommé pour son titre
donne moi ton coeur magnifique
franchement oui à la mairie
christopher consonance américaine j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment dégueulasse encore
une fois et il faut le dire il faut le
répéter non seulement aux jeunes filles
la première des libertés des femmes et
notamment aux jeunes qu'il faut leur
dire c'est la fin des libertés qu'elles
ont c'est de pouvoir disposer librement
de soin de leur corps et père noël a
jugé de comment ils sont comment ils se
comportent et c et j'espère que les
tables enfin ce s'emparer de ce sujet
pour caractériser la grossophobie
presque comme un délit et puis une
opinion c'est vrai mais c'est toujours
pareil c'est le problème des réseaux
sociaux et les gens balancent
l'important c'est l'animation
alors en fait ce que j'ai surtout
apprécié dans le comportement de lohan
segal la loisne pardon c'est qu'elle a
tweeté avec sobriété élégance et elle
n'a pas insulté comme a pu le faire il
ya quelques semaines l'ex miss france
qui a mais bon après il ya eu un
comportement un peu plus voilà
vulgaire dirons nous j'ai trouvé ça
c'est une guerre chacun son était très
smart très élégante et elle a répondu à
ses internautes je trouve ça plutôt
plutôt que tu as un viol